We focus on the idea of happiness too
much in the.
The problem with that is is that it
takes our focus away from ames that
would be more productive.
It's much better to aim for meaning then
for happiness.
12 rules for life is about how to live
properly in the face of vulnerability,
tragedy,
and malevolence.
One of the propositions in 12 rules for
life is that life existence is usefully
characterized as an interplay of order
and chaos or unknown unknown.
You're always striving to balance those
two.
If if,
if what you're doing is too familiar
your board and if what you're doing is
to unfamiliar,
then you're anxious and what you want to
do is find the,
the,
the harmonious line between those two,
but that's signified by leaning.
If you can get those two things right,
then you can have your cake and eat it
too.
I hope people can take away the idea
that there is a motive being in the face
of the vulnerability and tragedy of life
that is noble and powerful and capable
of sustaining them through the worst
possible times without becoming corrupt
and bitter.